bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
france 24 je reçois aujourd'hui
dominique reynié qui est politologue
directeur de la fondation pour
l'innovation politique
bonjour dominique reynié un jour vous
avez participé vous avez même dirigé une
vaste étude sur l'état de la démocratie
dans le monde à un moment finalement de
fortes tensions entre ces démocraties et
des puissances autoritaire d'une part et
puis même à l'intérieur même de ces
démocratie alors c'est une étude
planétaire qui s'intitule liberté
l'épreuve du siècle elle a été réalisée
dans 55 pays on le voit à l'antenne et
au total 47 mille personnes un
échantillon extrêmement vaste a répondu
à différentes questions alors ma
première question dominique reynié elle
va être toute simple pourquoi vous êtes
vous lancé dans une telle aventure est
ce que parce que vous estimez que le
danger finalement que ce soit un danger
extérieur ou intérieur est très grand
pour ces démocraties et qu'il fallait
essayer de rendre compte dans comprendre
les mécanismes oui merci pour votre
invitation merci de me permettre de
parler de cette enquête parce que en
effet le poids de départ
de déclencheur c'est un sentiment un peu
diffus que nous sommes en 2022 mais ça
fait quelques années déjà que nous
sommes dans une période assez troublante
où l'on ressent vous l'avez d'ailleurs
déjà indiqué une sorte de jeu de
pression qui s'exerce sur démocratie et
à l'intérieur des tensions qui
travaillent le monde démocratique et on
a presque
déjà la certitude que les démocraties
sont mises au défi de continuer à
exister dans ce siècle ça la période
semble beaucoup moins favorable au monde
démocratique confrontés à des problèmes
importants sur le plan économique
financier
démographique il ya beaucoup de sujets
et tout se passe comme si ces régimes
démocratiques
c'est une espèce dans tiennent que
l'entente ait bien été réputé moins
capables de s'en sortir que des régimes
autoritaires alors l'étude est
partagé entre différents chapitres le
premier chapitre s'appelle de qui les
démocraties ont peur alors clairement on
trouve dans l'ordre la chine la russie
bien également la turquie qui
dérange mais surtout qui désoriente 1
plutôt pas mal et les personnes
interrogées la chine ce n'est pas une
surprise je pense simplement on avait
fait une première enquête dans le 42
pays en 2018 la chine était beaucoup
moins impopulaire qu'aujourd'hui si je
puis dire il ya une dégradation
considérable de l'image de la chine dans
le monde démocratique
non pas qu'on ne veuille pas d'ailleurs
avoir des échanges avec la chine parce
que les questions sont le son sont
diverses mais en redoutent ce ce pouvoir
qui apparaît comme menaçants et qui que
l'on sait très autoritaire la turquie
vous vous en parliez
trouble les européens parce que c'est un
pays membre de l'otan qui devient
agressif avec des pays partenaires des
tensions fortes avec la grèce avec
chypre avec la france aussi par voie de
conséquence donc on ne sait plus très
bien au fond que veut la turquie et quel
rôle il veut jouer dans cet espace euro
asiatique alors l'image des états unis
elle elle s'est plutôt améliorée depuis
dix mille 18 et elle est toujours
considérée évidemment comme la puissance
la plus influente oui les états unis on
vous avez raison de souligner une image
qui s'est relevée depuis la précédente
mesure la précédente mesure en 2018
chacun peut peut s'en souvenir je veux
dire de la situation
nous allons nous étions vraiment du
tropisme
sinon triomphant du moins en pleine
expansion et l'image des états unis dans
le monde démocratique était épouvantable
avec joe biden il y a eu une
amélioration qui est durable ou pas
l'avenir va le dire mais on continue de
regarder dans ce monde démocratique dans
155 pays on continue de regarder les
états unis comme la puissance qui a le
plus d'influencé dans le monde
d'ailleurs la seule à laquelle on prête
une véritable influence la russie étant
considérés comme peu influentes mais
dangereuse pour ses voisins alors il y à
aussi dans cette étude des billets par
classe d'âge est sûre
le fait de redouter en quelque sorte ces
puissances autoritaire on s'aperçoit que
les jeunes générations les 18 35 ans
sont moins craintifs finalement que les
générations plus âgées ça s'explique par
l'optimisme lié à l'âge ça peut être le
petit mil ça peut être une façon de
moins se représenter les dangers les
périls peut-être que l'histoire est
moins présente dans l'esprit des
nouvelles générations
il peut y avoir aussi parce qu'on le
trouve j'ai cherché ces nouveaux
citoyens une sorte de compréhension
voire pour partie une adhésion à des
conceptions plus autoritaires de la
politique du gouvernement alors il ya un
chapitre aussi qui s'intitule cette fois
ci de quoi les démocraties ont peur et
c'est également très intéressant parce
que on voit qu'il ya une une forte
incertitude sécuritaire une baisse de la
confiance dans les relations entre les
personnes la peur d'un déclassement
économique bref les craintes sont eux
assez grand alors un symptôme assez
inquiétant de ces attitude craintive
presque 50% des personnes interrogées
par exemple sont favorables au droit
d'avoir une arme à feu chez soi même
s'il ya de très fortes disparités selon
les pays oui la question c'est une arme
à feu chez soi pour pouvoir se défendre
et défendre absolue et donc c'est très
précis et vous avez raison un sur deux
alors dans les 55 pays il ya des pays où
c'est autorisé et même garanti par la
constitution c'est le cas des états unis
mais néanmoins on observe que dans les
pays où le droit d'avoir une arme à feu
chez soi pour se défendre n'est pas
reconnu il ya une proportion
significative
un car un tiers parfois davantage de
citoyens qui ont le sentiment il ya un
chiffre très fort notamment sur le
continent européen où les chiffres sont
assez faibles mais pas comme la serbie
je crois que le chiffre est
impressionnant plus de 70 pour
absolument oui c'est vrai qu'il ya des
particularités historiques et
géographiques
mais de manière générale ce sentiment
que l'état la puissance publique est
moins à même de vous défendre
personnellement dans un monde agité
alors bon il ya beaucoup de questions
tout temps les avancées ici
mais de manière assez étonnante et
contrairement à ce qu'on entend assez
souvent et bien finalement on s'aperçoit
que l'attachement à l'union européenne
reste plutôt fort oui ça c'est très
clair à l'attachement des européens bien
sûr seulement à l'union européenne est
très fort en particulier à l'euro et
l'attachement à la monnaie européenne
absolument et c'est très important je
veux dire juste un argument parce que
les européens la zone euro ne veulent
pas revenir en arrière même si parfois
ils disent c'était quand même sympa
d'avoir s'abonner le rôle est rassuré
rassure la valeur de leur patrimoine et
donc ça veut dire aussi que toutes les
forces populistes qui s'agitent en
europe ne peuvent pas en réalité
promettre à sortait de l'euro sous peine
de ne pas réussir au plan électoral et
donc on a une intégration des populistes
dans le discours dans la vision
européenne par l'obligation qui leur est
faite du point de vue de l'opinion de
défendre l'euro et puis il ya aussi une
assez forte confiance finalement dans
les institutions politiques européennes
la commission européenne le parlement
qui sont souvent on discrédite est
considéré comme des forces obscures et
technocratique finalement même dans
certains pays européens la confiance
dans ses institutions européennes est
supérieure à la confiance dans les
institutions nationales seulement en
moyenne d'ailleurs en europe dans les 27
la confiance dans la commission
européenne est supérieure la confiance
entre en france je crois dans son
gouvernement national et la confiance
dans le parlement européen est supérieur
dans la confiance en son propre
parlement donc c'est une c'est une
situation qui est peu connu ça arrive
parce que vous vous l'avez dit on fait
souvent le procès des institutions
européennes mais elle vaut mieux au fond
en terme d'opinion que les nationales et
puis alors un rapport qui devrait faire
plaisir à emmanuel macron plus de la
moitié des européens sont favorables à
une armée européenne
absolument c'est cette idée de l'armée
européenne ça fait souvent sourire les
spécialistes des questions militaires
parce que c'est suis très technique et
très compliquée et qui touche à la
souveraineté la plus essentielle mais il
faut le relever les européens sont
favorables à une armée européenne
supplémentaires l'idc qui viendrait
appuyer les armées nationales et ça
correspond à leurs craintes face à des
menaces extérieures alors au final
dominique reynié malgré tout malgré
toutes ces difficultés malgré toutes ces
inquiétudes ont ces personnes dans votre
étude que le modèle démocratique ud
résiste quand même pas mal absolument ça
c'est là après toi c'était pas donné au
départ les dangers sont eux sont
exprimés et repérer mais l'attachement à
la démocratie représentative celle que
nous avons réuni 80 pour cent de tous
les répondants est beaucoup plus
impressionnant encore quoique ce chiffre
déjà élevé l'attachement aux libertés
compte que nous déclinons les
différentes libertés liberté de la
presse liberté d'opinion de choisir pour
qui ont voté etc on est à 95% 96% et
donc dans les peuples de ces démocraties
on ne veut pas se défaire des libertés
même si on peut avoir un regard très
sévère sur la manière dont fonctionne la
démocratie dans son pays même s'il ya je
crois environ à peu près un tiers des
répondants qui sont assez tenté par une
option bonapartiste un homme fort à la
tête du pays qui s'occupera pas trop du
parlement où des élections alors disons
que comme on leur demande d'évaluer
chaque option il ya six options si type
de régime si vous voulez ils n'ont pas à
choisir si bien que le régime
autoritaire on va le dire bien suscite
une forme de d'évaluations positives de
la part d'un tiers des répondants mais
le régime qui fait
le consensus c'est le régime de
démocratie représentative
alors dernier point très rapidement dans
cette opinion par contre le l'opinion on
va dire des personnes interrogées sur
leurs dirigeants est quand même assez
assez rude puisque je crois que 50 % des
répondants estiment que la plupart de
ces dirigeants sont corrompus alors la
corruption d'ailleurs un est considéré
comme la première menace par nos
personnes interrogées qui pèsent sur la
démocratie est en effet vous avez raison
malheureusement parce que c'est très
exagéré et c'est injustifié
il considère que la plupart des de ceux
qui nous gouvernent sont corrompus donc
c'est un peu à l'emporte-pièce
et ça signifie aussi l'état de suspicion
et de défiance vous en parliez dans
lequel le vivent nos régimes
démocratiques et leurs concitoyens voilà
aimer encore évidemment beaucoup
d'autres choses à lire dans cette étude
passionnante un rapport très instructif
sur l'état un peu d'inquiétude mais
finalement qui résiste pas mal de
démocratie en ce début des années 2020
rappelle le titre de cette étude liberté
l'épreuve du siècle c'est la fin de cet
entretien merci merci munich à lire sur
le site de la fonderie on pourra
télécharger gratuitement voilà donc à
télécharger gratuitement absolument
c'est la fin de cet entretien merci de
l'avoir suivi dans quelques minutes ce
sera bien sûr le retour de l'information
internationale sur france 24
[Musique]
france 24 et rfi présente retrouvez nous
tous les mardis soirs sur france 24 rfi
pour la nouvelle formule de mardi
politique plus longue plus dense avec
les acteurs de 2022 et donc de cette
présidentielle dans cette nouvelle
formule de mardi politique nous
interrogerons tous les candidats ou
leurs représentants sur les grands
thèmes de l'élection présidentielle mais
nous essaierons aussi de vous les faire
découvrir sous un autre jour du
personnel plus humain et puis bien sûr
la politique étrangère qui est l'adn de
nos deux médias donc rendez vous le
mardi soir sur france 24 et rfi mardi
politique à écouter sur rfi est à voir
sur france 24 et france24 com
[Musique]
parce que l'économie ça n'est pas que
des chiffres et des pauvres ce sont
aussi des chefs d'entreprise des
salariés des entrepreneurs des
chercheurs des décisions qui changent
notre vie en pâte que la société et la
planète pour mieux comprendre
l'actualité économique mondiale ne
manquez pas la semaine de l'écho sur
france 24 et sur france 24 points
la semaine de l'écho à voir sur france
24 et sur france 24 points comme
[Musique]